[Music]
it's ps plus time yet again the mid
month update to the games catalog this
time it adds a total of 19 games across
both extra and premium tiers everything
you see on this video is playable from
september 20th so let's start with the
extra lineup death loop is our first ps5
offering from the creators of dishonored
comes a time loop first person shooter
in which we play an assassin who must
take out eight targets in a single day
should we fail the day begins all over
again everything is reset and we re-plan
knowing where our targets will be at
each moment in the day the thing is
there's another assassin with the same
skill set as us and she is coming for
you death loop has an invasion mode
allowing other players to play that
character to jump into your game and
hunt you down and of course you can do
the same and jump into their game and
ruin their progress death loop released
to many 10 out of 10 review scores and i
have to admit i reviewed it at 7.5 out
of 10. to know if it is a perfect 10
game or just very good you'll have to
play it yourself over on the ps4 is the
unbelievably huge rpg assassin's creed
origins learn about the early days of
the brotherhood by traveling to egypt i
can't underplay the rpg elements back in
2017 this was a real shift away from
stealth action of the older games and
origins made weapon upgrades multiple
weapon types and grinding for levels the
new core of assassin's creed you'll need
at least 30 hours to fulfill the story
and there's another 30 hours of side
content to play through there is so much
to do in origins from discovering hidden
temples with tomb raider style puzzles
to taking on sea warfare black flag
style reviewers tell us this is an 8.5
out of 10. next another ubisoft banger
watch dogs 2 this time we fill the boots
of marcus holloway a hacker in san
francisco the premise always makes me
think of a modern day assassin's creed
we fight the systems of power as a
member of dedsec a hacker group turned
vigilantes watchdogs drops you into a
sandbox world with a bunch of toys and
lets you use them however you please to
complete missions drones stealth hacking
sending poor intel to other gangs to
have them fight each other whilst you
watch from the rooftops there's many
ways to get the job done and like the
previous game other players can jump
into your game and attempt to hack you
for information ultimately watchdogs 2
reviews at 8 out of 10. so will you go
back next dragon ball xenoverse 2 a
role-playing fighter crossed with an rpg
definitely one for the die-hard dragon
ball fans recreate a character and
slowly build up their power level in
order to fight more iconic enemies from
the tv show the core fighting can be as
simple as combo spamming yet play long
enough and you'll be managing meters and
cancelling combos to immediately start a
different one all whilst fighting in
every direction possible the story is
cleverly written around a new set of bad
guys who are changing the history of
dragon ball which means we have to step
in and make sure the real cannon stories
are kept intact xenoverse 2 is a solid
option next chicory a colourful tale a
small adventure game filled with puzzles
paint and a rather good story i'm told
we wield a magic paintbrush and we must
bring the world back to life as we
progress the narrative we unlock new
brushes and paint colors which then
become part of the core mechanic as an
indie game chicory scored really well
with pro reviewers giving it nine out of
ten so i guess we should try this how
good is the scott pilgrim movie did it
leave you wanting to see more of that
universe may i suggest scott pilgrim vs
the world the game complete edition a 2d
arcade brawler that takes the comic book
and the movies and jams them into a side
scroller a good gamer can get this done
within two hours need a platformer take
a look at rayman legends it may be
almost a decade old but hey it's still
great rayman legends has so many unique
ideas that makes 10 hours of gameplay go
in an instant if you never played it i
recommend it and so did the reviewers
back then ign gave it 9.5 out of 10.
another nostalgic platformer is alex
kidd in miracle world dx the really cool
thing here is the ability to switch eras
the original game was made in the 1980s
and you can switch to that with one
button or keep it super modern in the
2020s instead the best thing about
miracle world is its dedication to play
like a game made 30 years ago the worst
thing about miracle world is its
dedication to play like a game made 30
years ago i guess she can't please
everyone next we have spirit fairer how
can i put this it's a game about dying
we play a stella who is responsible for
ferrying the deceased to the afterlife
she picks up beings who are represented
through animals when they join her
vessel our job is to help them come to
terms and complete all unfinished tasks
in their life before they move to the
afterlife okay more upbeat next is
rabbids invasion the interactive tv show
this is a strange one basically you'll
watch 20 episodes of rabbids and by
plugging in a camera you can take part
in activities on screen
and what about a racing game this month
it's monster energy supercross the
official video game five that's a long
ass title there is a multiplayer there
is a track creation and a bunch of dirt
too you'll already know if you want to
play this okay is anyone actually still
here cause now we're moving on to ps
plus premium content and for this month
there's another bunch of retro classics
the sly collection is here which
includes the original sly cooper sly 2
band of thieves sly 3 honor amongst
thieves and then we have sly cooper
thieves in time and if that isn't enough
sly cooper for you there's bentley's
hack pack which is a bunch of arcade
mini games for fans of action shooters
we have siphon filter 2 from the ps1 as
gabe and zing return and for movie fans
we have toy story 3 on the psp and also
kingdom of paradise finding footage for
these games is tough hence why i went
through them quite quickly so that's
september for extra and premium ps plus
subscribers a total of 19 games to play
how will you find the time i'm adam
you're awesome peace